[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICHARD GAYWOOD:
My name is Richard.
I work in London with the
Google Play Console Team.
And I'm here today to talk to
you about Pre-Launch Report.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: And I am
Justin, Tech Lead Manager
for the Firebase Test Lab.
Thank you, the brave
few who have made it
at this rather ungodly hour,
the night after the party.
And I'm sure that that scary,
rather wordy title didn't help.
Did we really used
the word autonomous?
RICHARD GAYWOOD:
Marketing insisted.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: So if
you're here for a Waymo talk,
you're in the wrong place.
Today, we're here to talk to you
about intelligent app and game
testing that requires mercifully
little work on your part.
It's available in
both the Play Console
and in Firebase Test Lab.
Both products have massively
increased their offering.
And we're here to
tell you about what's
in one, what's in the
other, and what's in both.
And we'll tell you our story
in the context of an app.
Testing is a pain.
But as you've probably heard
multiple times this week,
it's really important.
So as much as possible, we
want to take Google's expertise
and resources, and make
it our pain and not yours.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: So let's start
by talking about the Pre-Launch
Report.
This is an automated
scan of your app
that aims to give you an early
warning of quality problems
before your users see them.
It's a free service.
And it applies automatically
to every APK published
to Play's Alpha or
Beta tracks, or as you
may have heard this week, the
new open and closed testing
tracks.
We take APKs that you
pass to Google Play.
And we install them
onto about 10 devices.
These devices span a range.
There are high-end
devices, like the Pixel 2,
and down to low-end devices
like the Samsung Galaxy J1 Ace.
Once we have the APK
installed on the device,
we start a special
robo crawler process.
The robo crawler explores
your app, inputting taps,
and swipes, and text
as a user would.
This takes place on
physical infrastructure
which is part of a larger
farm, with thousands
of different devices and a
large diversity of hardware
and operating systems.
Your fellow developers
have told us
that they take Pre-Launch
Report very seriously.
In a recent survey, 86%
said that they consider
Pre-Launch Report results to
be important or very important
when they're considering
whether it's time to launch
a new app into production.
When developers have
ignored our recommendation
and launched in something
that we found problems,
our data says that about 75% of
the time, the problems that we
found in Pre-Launch Report
were later seen by real users.
Those users got a
poor experience.
They may have left bad reviews.
They may have left bad ratings.
They may have chosen not
to spend money in the app.
And they may even have
uninstalled the app.
Furthermore, Pre-Launch
Report test results
are used internally within Play
as one of a number of factors
when deciding how to feature
and rank apps in the Play Store.
As of today, we've crawled
over a million different apps.
And if we're not
already crawling yours,
we'd really like
to be doing that.
Now, as you've probably
guessed from what I've said,
Pre-Launch Report is pretty
good at finding crashes.
When we find a crash in
your app while we test it,
we give you a lot of
information-- stack traces,
log [INAUDIBLE],,
things like that--
everything you need to
debug the crash and fix it.
But we don't just do crashes.
We also take
screenshots and capture
a video of the
crawl on each device
so that you can look for UX
issues in different languages.
In October, we added
performance data.
This is network,
memory, and CPU metrics
so that you can look for
performance issues in your app.
So that's what my team does,
the Play Pre-Launch Report.
What about your team, Justin?
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: So my team
works on Firebase Test Lab.
So Firebase Test Lab
is a separate solution
that is part of the suite of
products under the Firebase
umbrella.
It uses the same technology
as the Pre-Launch Report,
including the larger device
farm that Richard mentioned.
It offers many of
the same features.
But it also integrates with
a number of different tools,
such as Android Studio,
fastlane, gcloud SDK,
and of course, the
Firebase console,
allowing developers
to test their apps
and games at all stages of
the application lifecycle
across a wider array of
devices, giving you more
comprehensive test results.
So let's talk about an app.
This is Fitness Bud.
Now, while Fitness Bud is
not a real application,
it does illustrate
real-world problems--
problems we know you will have.
Fitness Bud is a social
fitness tracking application
built by, let's say, a
small company, FB Solutions.
Fitness Bud allows you
to log in with a Google
account or a custom account,
create an online fitness
avatar, invite fitness
buddies with whom to train,
and even join a local gym.
Richard and I are
going to take you
through how FB Solutions makes
use of the many new tools
at their disposal to
develop, test, and release
their soon-to-be wildly
successful application.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: Thanks, Justin.
Now, as my wife
likes to remind me
when I'm being smug
about something,
my body shape is best
described as a potato on legs.
So I really need Fitness
Bud to be very, very good.
I need all the help I can get.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: So how many
of you have spouses like-- no,
sorry.
How many of you have
way more time than you
know what to do with and can fix
every last problem in your app?
Nobody?
RICHARD GAYWOOD:
Yeah, neither do we.
With all of the signals
that Pre-Launch Report makes
available to you,
we know it can be
hard to prioritize, to
decide which of these issues
is the most urgent
that you should fix.
So starting this week,
we've launched a new page
which digests all
of the issues we've
found into a single
launch recommendation,
as you can see here.
This shows up at the top
of our new Overview tab.
The Overview tab then
displays all of the issues
that Pre-Launch Report has
found, prioritized by severity.
This new tab makes it easy for
Fitness Bud to see at a glance
if this new APK that they
have as a release candidate
is ready to be released
to users or not.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Now, Test
Lab's intelligent crawler
does a great job of crawling
the Android framework
part of Fitness Bud.
But Fitness Bud uses OpenGL
for an online fitness avatar
creation part.
Previously, the
Pre-Launch Report
couldn't test apps and
games which used OpenGL,
but now it can.
If you're a game
developer, you can write
what are called Demo Loops.
Demo Loops are an automated
journey through your app.
They can focus on a particular
level or a particular game
character.
Demo Loops are a great way--
they are an intent filter that
is declared in your manifest.
They're not normally called
as part of the normal running
of your application.
But our test infrastructure
will detect them and run them.
Demo Loops launched last
year in Firebase Test Lab.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: And
starting this week,
Demo Loops are now available
in Pre-Launch Report, as well.
So if you choose to add
a Demo Loop to your app,
when we take your app through
Pre-Launch Report, rather than
the usual robo crawler,
we will run the Demo Loop
and then output the full set
of Pre-Launch Report output.
We'll look for crashes.
And most importantly, we'll give
you those performance traces,
so you can use Demo
Loops for accurate
benchmarking on our
range of devices.
If you don't use a Demo Loop,
we will use another new feature
called Monkey Actions.
When we detect that the
crawler has discovered
an OpenGL part of
your app, we'll
fall back to random input,
so we get at least some
crawling for you.
Fitness Bud really cares
about keeping its users'
data safe and secure.
So Fitness Bud requires custom
login or log in with Google.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: And if you
use Firebase Auth, both of these
are supported.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: As I was
saying before I was so rudely
interrupted by that
message from our sponsors,
Pre-Launch Report uses
an auto-login feature.
As we test your
app, or as we test
Fitness Bud's app, when we see
a Sign In with Google button.
We will use it.
And we automatically
have a Google account
on the device, ready
to be signed in.
Applications that don't
use log in with Google
can choose to configure
Pre-Launch Report
with a username or an email
address and a password
that we will again use to
get past the login screen
when we see it.
Next, let's talk
about Deep Links.
Deep Links are a way for
users to invoke functionality
within your app that bypasses
the normal entry flow.
For example, a user might
start off searching the web,
but should be shown those
search results within your app.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON:
So how many of you
have Deep Links in your apps?
Wow, yeah.
How many of you test
those Deep Links
at every release of the app?
One, two?
RICHARD GAYWOOD: I salute you.
So Fitness Bud
have this problem.
They use Deep Links to encourage
users to sign up to local gyms.
The user receives a Firebase
notification alerting them
to a special offer.
They click the link
in the notification,
and they're taken straight
to Firebase's gym signup--
to Fitness Bud's
gym signup screen.
This is a very
important flow for them,
because money changes hands.
Launching this week,
Pre-Launch Report
will now test up to
three Deep Links.
You can configure it
and add the Deep Links.
We crawl as usual
for the five minutes,
then at the end of the
crawl, we close the app
and visit each
Deep Link in turn.
As we visit each Deep Link, we
crawl for a further 30 seconds.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: So
Fitness Bud and you
can make sure that users
who follow Deep Links
can have the same
great experience.
So as we have seen from
the million-plus apps
that the crawler has
tested, sometimes,
crucial parts of an
application are only
reached through some
complicated flow,
like Fitness Bud's
gym signup form.
It turns out that automated
crawlers, and even some humans,
aren't that good at
entering the correct text
to bypass this form.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: So this is
where Robo Scripts come in.
These are another new feature.
Robo Scripts provide
guidance to our crawler
to get past a complicated
part of the app.
They take the form of a short,
scripted sequence of actions
recorded as JSON file.
You can record Robo
Scripts using a tool built
into Android Studio.
With the app
running locally, you
record a series of
taps and swipes.
You then upload the scripts
to Pre-Launch Report
or to Firebase Test Lab.
The Robo Script guides the
early part of the crawl,
carrying out the
prerecorded sequences
to get the app into some
state that you think
will be interesting to test.
Once it's completed
the Robo Script,
it starts crawling normally.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Now,
Robo Scripts are not
only useful for crawling forms.
They can also be used to guide
the crawler past any parts
that it finds
tricky to navigate.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: Usability
and accessibility
are really important
to your app.
If you make your touch
targets too small,
you might have a
result like this.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: (ON VIDEO)
RICHARD GAYWOOD: Not one of your
better days at the gym, Justin?
Does that happen to you a lot?
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Actually, no.
But I do seem to have a rather
persistent irrational fear
of treadmills.
And I haven't been on one since.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: I think
that's probably wise.
In the next few
weeks, we're going
to add to Pre-Launch Report
an intelligent crawler that's
going to help uncover
usability issues,
like that tiny button
that poor Justin was
trying so hard to click there.
All jokes aside, though,
small touch targets are
a problem for a
wide range of users,
including users using your
app on the go one-handed
or uses with
dexterity impairments.
Legible text is also
extremely important.
So we will warn you
when text is too small.
Or we will warn you when
the contrast is too low.
Some visually impaired users
rely heavily on TalkBack.
So we will also tell you when
TalkBack voiceover annotations
are missing or confusing.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON:
And as you can tell,
that infamous button I was
trying so hard to click
is included in the
usability results.
And it's got a big
red box around it.
And thankfully, as
far as I'm concerned,
it's marked as Should Fix.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: So after a
full sprint of bug fixing,
Fitness Bud uploads a fresh
APK to the Google Play Console.
And they take another look
at the Pre-Launch Report's
Overview tab.
As you can see here,
there are no longer
any serious issues detected.
They can now push this APK
into their production channel,
confident that their users will
be receiving a good experience.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: So
we hope that you, too,
can adopt the Pre-Launch
Report as part of your decision
to launch.
RICHARD GAYWOOD:
So that's what you
get in Pre-Launch
Report, which is
available for free to everyone
who publishes APKs to what we
used to call the Alpha
or Beta channels,
but now call open and
closed testing tracks.
You can find it in the Google
Play Console and the Manage
Releases.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON:
Thank you, Richard.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: You're welcome.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON:
So as developers,
we know that the earlier
we catch problems,
the easier they are to fix.
So if you're a
conscientious developer,
or you just like
saving money, you
want to catch problems
as quickly as possible.
This is where Firebase
Test Lab comes in.
Now, many of us,
myself included,
have discussed ad nauseam
about the importance
of creating automated tests for
every part of your application
and to run those
tests continuously
to prevent regressions.
This is honestly the
most important thing
you can do to improve the
quality of your applications.
But writing tests is hard.
That's why, when I ask,
in gatherings like this,
how many of you have
automated tests that
cover every part of your
application, way too few of you
put up your hands.
So I gave up
nagging a while ago.
And we at Google have
put a lot of focus
into creating tests
for apps and games
without actually having
to write those tests.
Earlier, we saw the
automated crawler,
which is part of
Firebase Test Lab as what
we call a robo test.
But we can do much more.
Let's look at how
we can create tests
for all the different
parts of Fitness Bud.
So one of the first things that
I, as a user of Fitness Bud,
will want to do, is create
my fitness avatar, which
involves uploading my photo.
And from that photo--
there it is-- the
app actually creates
a caricature of me, which seems
to have emphasized all my worst
flaws.
It then allows me to choose
a focused activity, weight
training.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: Is that
really you up there, Justin?
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Well, it
appears that my ears are not
my worst flaw.
Vanity is.
Then, I get to guide my
excessively buffed avatar
around the various
gym activities,
with all my equally
unrealistic fitness buddies.
Now, all this avatar
stuff is written in OpenGL
for a more immersive and
fun experience for the user.
And previously, it's been hard
to test apps and games which
use OpenGL.
But over the last
year, we at Google
have introduced a couple of
ways in which you can now
do this more easily.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: So we
introduced at I/O last year
the concept of Demo Loops that
Justin and I discussed earlier.
And Pre-Launch Report
now runs Demo Loops
in your apps and games if
you choose to include them.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON:
Now, Fitness Bud
can construct Demo Loops
for all this avatar stuff
by simply recording
and replaying
their OpenGL commands.
And then during
testing, they can
verify that they don't see
crashes or performance issues.
Now, Fitness Bud can run
these Demo Loops locally
on their devices, using
an app that we created
that's freely available.
But more importantly, they
can run those Demo Loops
in Firebase Test Lab across
a wide array of devices.
Secondly, we announced at the
Games Developer Conference
earlier on this year a
collaboration with NetEase
to create tests for games
that run in Firebase Test Lab.
NetEase is one of the
largest games development
companies in China.
And as part of
this collaboration,
they open-sourced their
test environment, AirTest,
along with a couple
of frameworks
that they use internally
for developing
tests for their own games.
Now, you can download
this testing framework.
There is a link at the end.
And with it, you
can create tests
that add actions and assertions
that refer to game elements.
So let's see how that works.
So here's AirTest.
And I'm just going to
select Game Elements
and add an action to
touch a game element.
I can wait for a game
element to exist,
or I can assert that the
game element is visible.
It's that simple.
Like Demo Loops, these
tests can be run locally.
But they can also be
run in Firebase Test Lab
across a wide array of devices.
Now, here's the goal creation
screen for Fitness Bud.
Now, my fitness goals are pretty
modest, as you saw earlier.
It's a good day if I don't
fall off a treadmill.
With this screen, users
get to create fitness goals
and share them with all
their fitness buddies.
Now, obviously,
Fitness Bud wants
to create tests that cover
this part of the app, as well.
Now, typically, this involves
laboriously writing tests
in one of the many
testing frameworks,
such as Espresso
or UI Automator,
and then keeping those tests
updated as the UI evolves.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: So I want to
know, actually-- let me quickly
ask, how many of you have had
to rewrite dozens, or even
hundreds, of UI tests
because you made
some small change in your app?
Right?
And it's really painful, right?
This has happened to me, too.
I know exactly that this is
a really painful situation.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: So this
is the exact reason why we
built Espresso Test Recorder.
Espresso Test Recorder is
part of Android Studio.
And with it, you can quickly
record Espresso tests
by simply interacting
with your device running
your app locally.
With it, we can
create lots of tests
that cover the non-OpenGL
parts Fitness Bud.
Now, you can create these
tests in either Java or Kotlin.
But the best thing is that
if your UI does change,
you can go back in and
easily rerecord those tests.
Let's see how this works.
All right, this is
Android Studio here.
I'm going to choose to
record an Espresso test.
I'm going to pick my local
Pixel 2, which is running.
Then it compiles
and installs my app
and brings up this event window.
And at this point, I
get to enter my name,
click on an avatar, and
it records the events,
all there in that window.
Next, I want to
add an assertion.
So adding an assertion
involves pulling a screenshot
from the device so that
I can select elements
in that screenshot on
which I want to assert.
I will do that,
click on an element.
And then I'm going to click OK.
I get to choose Java or Kotlin.
I'm going to choose Kotlin.
I'm going to click OK.
And there is my
Kotlin test class.
It's that simple.
With the Espresso
Test Recorder, you
can modularize your testing.
You can create test snippets
for the commonly used functions
in all your tests, such as
logging in or filling out
a search form.
And so with all that free
time, all those excuses
for not going to the
gym simply evaporate.
So now, Fitness Bud
has a battery of tests.
And all they have
to do is add them
to their continuous
integration system.
And now, every time
they make a change,
they can be much more confident.
This is the beauty--
much more confident
that it did not break
the app in some obscure way.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: And speaking
as a developer myself,
peace of mind like that
is honestly priceless.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON:
But Fitness Bud
is going to have to run
on the myriad of devices
that people drag to the gym.
How do they make sure
that the app runs well
on all those devices?
Well, they could buy a
whole bunch of devices,
hook them up to a
workstation, and stick them
in a closet somewhere.
But Fitness Bud's closets
are full of gym bags,
because they practice
what they preach.
Plus, maintaining
a device closet
is a really hard and
soul-destroying activity.
Trust me on this.
Not only do you have to keep
the devices online and updated,
but you also have to procure
new ones as the old ones die,
or explode, and fresh ones
come out onto the market.
Fitness Bud would much rather
be cutting code or pumping iron.
So what's the alternative?
RICHARD GAYWOOD: So Justin and
I have already described to you
how Pre-Launch Report offers
free crawler testing on about
10 devices--
so every APK that
Fitness Bud upload.
But you can go much further
with the Firebase Test Lab,
using a broader
range of devices,
covering an even wider gamma
of screen sizes, Android API
versions, different OEMs,
and different chipsets.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: And
so to illustrate this,
we recently added
prerelease P devices
that you can now all test on.
But what I'm most excited today
to announce-- wait for it--
is our new support for iOS.
Oops, it was already up there.
All right.
You already knew.
So you can sign up for a beta
through the Firebase Console.
It has a link at the end.
Fitness Bud is a
global application.
And as such, it needs to
be tested on a whole bunch
of different languages.
Both Firebase Test Lab
and the Play Console
allow you to do just that.
With Firebase Test Lab,
you can run your tests
on any locale you wish.
And Pre-Launch Report recommends
the most popular languages
amongst your users.
So now, there should be
no reason for Fitness Bud
to waste all that time and
energy maintaining a device
closet, which gives them even
more time to spend at the gym.
It's kind of a wonder they
get any coding done, actually.
Like in the Pre-Launch
Report, Firebase Test Lab
also gives you comprehensive
test results, like crashes
and ANRs, video and screenshots,
logs, performance metrics,
a map of the activities
the crawler found.
The video and screenshots
are especially
important to help Fitness Bud
verify that their app looks
good and runs well across
all those screen sizes,
and orientations, and locales.
Let's look at how easy
it is to quickly run
a test in the Firebase console.
Firstly, I want to quickly
point out our new iOS support.
There it is.
I'm going to dismiss
that coach mark.
But it's there.
We're going to run a Robo Test.
Robo Test is the
simplest of tests.
All it requires is that
you give us your app.
Now, I'm going to quickly
choose an app at random
from my hard disk
there and upload it.
While it's uploading,
you'll note,
we can also upload
a Robo Script, which
we're not going to do here.
But now, I get to
choose my devices
from amongst the many devices.
Some of these devices
are deprecated,
which means they exploded, and
we can no longer procure them.
I'm going to just go with
the default two devices.
But I do want to
add some locales.
I'm going to add Chinese.
I'm going to add Arabic
when I get there.
And then lastly, I'm
going to add Spanish.
And then I'm going to fix
the locales, because I really
only care about portrait mode.
And then-- fix the
locales, please.
There we go.
Then, I'm going to
start eight tests--
eight tests, because it's two
devices times four locales.
So now, what Test Lab is going
to do is, in the background,
it will allocate eight devices.
It will configure
those devices, setting
the locale, the orientation.
It will then install my
app on all those devices.
And then it will run a
five-minute Robot Test,
which will take five minutes.
So-- oh, thank god, it's done.
All right, there we go.
I'm going to pick
the first of these.
You see, we have logs.
We have screenshots.
We have an activity
map, which is a map
of the activities we visited.
You have performance
information,
which is tied to
the video, so you
can see what's
happening in your app
at the time of the CPU
spikes, or the eight
frames per second drops.
You can find
instructions on the web,
on the Firebase
documentation site,
for how to hook Test Lab up
to many common continuous
integration systems,
like Jenkins,
or CircleCI, or TeamCity.
We have a number of customers
who are doing exactly this--
testing their app
multiple times a day.
Test Lab is helping them find
problems way before they end up
affecting their users.
And best of all, you
can get started for free
with our Spark billing tier.
So it's really that simple.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: Justin and I
hope that our talk here today
can give you a renewed
inspiration for your testing
strategy.
It doesn't have to be difficult
to test comprehensively.
Let the Pre-Launch Report
and the Google Play Console
help you discover crashes,
performance issues, security
vulnerabilities, and soon,
accessibility warnings
with zero configuration
required from you.
Just publish an APK to the
open or closed testing tracks,
and a report will be
generated for you.
You can go further than
the auto-generated report
by giving us custom login
credentials, Robo Scripts, Deep
Links, and Demo Loops to
help us test your app better.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON:
And if you want
to test maybe more often,
maybe more comprehensively,
take a look at Firebase
Test Lab, which, in addition
to the features
Richard just mentioned,
also allows you to create
and run your own tests.
So take a picture
of this if you wish.
I'll give you a couple
of seconds do that.
I think most people
have already done that.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: We'd really
love to hear more from you.
So if you have any
comments or suggestions,
please use the link
in the I/O app or come
find us in person
after the talk.
Thank you very much.
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Thank you.
RICHARD GAYWOOD: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]